okay i've used my sophisticated
artistic skills to draw a petri dish
okay two petri dishes
so i'm gonna give you a scenario and
show you how exponential growth and
decay plays out in a
pretty normal situation okay
so here we go um we're monitoring a
petri dish
and a bacterial population in it over
time all right
so when we first start out with our
little
colony of bacteria we count through some
unknown method of
precisely counting bacteria that there
are 5 000
bacteria living in our petri dish okay
half an hour passes
and when you come back using your same
very precise method
um you count that there are 20 000. see
can't you see
there's so many more bacteria in that
because that's totally what growing
bacteria looks like anyway
now assuming natural growth in decay i'm
going to give you three questions so you
might want to jot this down
apart from these details okay number one
assuming natural growth can you find the
population
as a function of time
you find a population let's call it p
right
and our function of time let's call our
unit let's go with minutes that's a nice
easy
unit to go with okay so there's our
first question find population is a
function of time
number two can we find the time
at which the population will hit a
hundred thousand
okay when is it going to get to
this population times okay
ah the third question has just two parts
two which are very very similar to each
other
these are about the actual quantity
right but one of the big things about
exponential growth and decay is not just
what the population is but how fast is
growing or decaying
okay so question three is about the rate
of the population's change
okay we want to know the rate at two
particular points
number one well part a
after an hour
what is that rate okay and since we're
looking at
bacteria and minutes then our rate will
be in terms of bacteria per minute
okay so what is it after one hour and
what is it
when there are 50 000 bacteria
okay so we're going to find the function
we're just going to find okay how long
does it take to grow to a certain size
and then we're going to have a look at
the rate
try and get it at a couple of different
spots all right
so how do we set this out well the first
way we start
is we say this is question one right
assuming natural growth now the question
may say that to you
as i did earlier on because sometimes a
scenario will not
and based on the kind of situation they
give you for instance a population
growing
or some radioactive substance decaying
okay you have to
assume all right this is the kind of
scenario that they've got in mind so you
would including your answer
assuming natural growth okay now
remember
the whole definition of natural growth
is that the rate of change
is going to be what was that keyword do
you remember
it's in a ratio with the um with the
quantity but what was the word we used
in proportion right so we're going to
have our rate of change
so that will be dp on dt
okay and that's going to be equal to
the population multiplied by sum
okay now by the way you may have seen in
the previous example i gave you okay
that this k it's just a constant right
so it could be um
a whole number that could be larger
number or it could be a small number
could be a fraction okay
it doesn't actually matter which side
you put the k on and just i'm sort of
second guessing myself
i think it might actually be more
helpful for us as we solve this to put
the k on the other side you'll see why
in a second
okay so really these equations are
equivalent they're still about they're
still proportional
okay but this is just working for the
algebra in a second
now being that this is the kind of
proportion we've got therefore the kind
of function we're talking about
is an exponential right so you can say
therefore
p is going to be equal to and this is
what i gave you before
okay now we're going to nut out what
these two bits and pieces are
but i need to say i should have set up
here k is
a real number okay usually they specify
k is positive
and here i'm introducing another
constant so i should say a
is a real number all right
now with these two unknowns okay i'm
going to use the information in the
question to work out what they
are in very much the same way that you
use like say initial conditions
to work out what like the constant of
integration is in a motion question
okay so using this is our starting point
and these pieces of information here
okay
how am i going to work out what my a and
my k are
we'll start with a right so based on the
initial conditions
okay they tell you that the population
starts at 5 000. right so therefore 5
000
that's the p population that's equal to
a e to the k now time for initial
conditions is
zero right so multiplied by zero
are you happy with that there you can
see what's happening here right
e to the that k becomes you know
uh doesn't matter so it's trivial e to
the zero is just
one right so this part just sort of
factors out the equation so therefore
a is actually just our starting
population
now for this reason instead of a uh even
though that's
the way the textbooks were said you
often see instead of a in this case
we've got a population p
so sometimes you'll see this called p
naught okay as in the population at time
zero
okay um sometimes when you're dealing
with a radioactive substance or
something else that's decaying
okay because you're dealing with mass
instead of p you'll have
m instead of p naught you'll have
m norm okay so get used to that instead
of a e and kt you could just as equally
have rich p naught
e to the kt and for you that's just to
signify okay
that coefficient there that tells me
where i start
all right so now i can rewrite my
equation for the population p is equal
to
5 000 invocation
now the other constant we have to get
rid of
will be from the other condition that we
know right
so after half an hour it's quadrupled in
size so what kind of equation
can i form what should i write
we got this one out of our initial
conditions right
so the two bits that we know that we're
going to input in
are number one the time and number two
what the population is actually equal to
at that point and just as a side note we
didn't have to choose minutes we could
have done hours
right and time would have just been 0.5
no problems you come up with exactly the
same answer
but we just sort of pick our units so we
get nice numbers integers
so i'm going to say well the population
at this point is now
20 000.
okay don't need to say any more because
i know exactly what a is that's five
thousand
and this will be e to the power of now
t is 30. right so therefore i'm going to
put in 30k
up here we want to make k the subject so
just a little bit of work to get there
let's divide through by 5
000. so that gives you 4. your 8 and 30k
so now that i have um k in the right you
know
up here on its own it's the only value
left how do i rewrite this
how do i rearrange
good so exponential equation to a log
equation the power becomes the subject
which is the whole point you know that's
why we're rewriting it like this okay
this base here becomes the base of the
new log right
so this is log base e this is natural
log of the only other number that's left
which is fault
so if you want k therefore what you have
is
1 on 30
okay or log what they doesn't matter
so that's all the pieces we need let's
just tie it all up in a nice
knot um there's my k there's my a
therefore the population b can be
expressed as
5 000 e to the
now with k remember we called this k uh
the
the constant of proportionality so this
tells you where you begin
okay this tells you how fast you grow
okay so it has the effect of stretching
things out do you remember when we were
graphing
you know say e to the x
versus e to the 2x or e to the 3x
okay what's the difference between all
of these okay well when you think about
it
if you put e to the x here okay changing
that
index will make it still go through it's
still at the same intercept
right but it's going to grow faster and
it's also going to decay
faster right sorry it's a bit wonky but
you're getting the idea
and that would be three x right so
whether you're decreeing
decaying or growing everything will
happen faster so
that's what this number here defines
okay how how do things go from one to
another which is why we use
this condition and this condition
together to
okay so therefore i'm going to try and
keep it together so rather than writing
up here i've got kt right rather than
writing t on 30 log 4
i'm going to keep that as one thing it's
a really important number and i want to
highlight it on its own so i've got one
on
30 log for t
okay i mean it doesn't really matter
where you put the t
but i think that's a helpful way to
write it